with us now from Capitol Hill is South
Dakota Senator John Thune chairman of
the Senate Republican Conference that
makes him the third ranking Republican
in the Senate senator Thune always good
to see you thanks for joining us this
morning good moring thanks good to be
with you let's begin first with your
colleague Senator John McCain how is the
news of his brain cancer affecting all
of you in the Senate that diagnosis was
made this an incredibly sad day as you
would expect on Capitol Hill John McCain
has beloved up here on both sides of the
aisle he is a hero to me and all of our
colleagues and the millions of Americans
and in people literally all over the
world so we are all hoping and praying
for him and for Cindy and his family as
he battles us he says he's going to be
back at work you don't doubt him right
he is relentless he's a warrior I've
traveled you know outside the United
States a number of times with him and
I've seen him work guys half his age
into the ground he is he is remarkable
in the minute individual it is
remarkable and also how well he has
spoken off in the Senate in terms of his
ability as a warrior as you have said
can we turn to healthcare and where we
stand today right Charlie well at the
moment we we are trying to get to 50
votes in the Senate on something that
would repeal and replace Obamacare we
know that the markets are collapsing
prices have been skyrocketing for people
in this country and something has to be
done but the one thing that's becoming
very clear is that it's I think that
among our members at least a
one-size-fits-all solution out of
Washington just really isn't going to
work and I think one of the fundamental
flaws of Obamacare is it tried to define
in federal law for the entire country
what health insurance is and I think
what we're hearing from our members is
every state is different every state has
different populations governors want
have different ideas and I think
anything that's effective and ultimately
passes the Senate is going to have to
distribute and shift Authority and power
and flexibility back to the states yeah
President Trump said you're very close
to getting something done is that how
you'd characterize it well I guess I
would say that we're gonna need a little
longer runway
I don't think we're getting close we are
but we still have some issues that we
have to resolve and we've got some
members who aren't quite there yet so we
don't have the 50 volts that we're gonna
need to get this across the finish line
just yet but I think eventually we will
the president publicly pressuring you
not to go on your vacation and take your
recess one day he's saying to repeal it
the other day he's saying to repeal and
replace it one of your colleagues in the
in the Senate your Republican colleagues
said the president scares no one in the
Senate not even the pages what is your
reaction to that well look I think that
the president has an important role to
play and particularly he's got the bully
pulpit and his roles with the American
people and engaging them in the
conversation about why it's important
that we that we fix this
I think senators up here obviously
looked to him for leadership in that
respect and his team's been very
involved in the day-to-day conversations
that we're having about this but
ultimately it's a function of the
Congress we have to get this done the
house is after the Senate now has
responsibility to act and I think the
American people will and should hold us
accountable you're you are aware this
New York Times interview with the
president obviously does this make it
difficult for your former colleague Jeff
session from Alabama now the Attorney
General to continue when the president
says what he says well I guess what I
what I would say that charlie is I you
know serve in Jeff Sessions we all
admire and respect him and his abilities
if I were him I would just do his job do
his job well and sort of ignore the
daily news cycle coming out of the White
House because I don't expect that's
going to change and I think he's got an
important job to do one that we can
confirmed him for here in the United
States Senate and I think he has a
confidence certainly of people here on
Capitol Hill and folks at the Justice
Department and that's what's most
important do you have concerns about the
meetings that President Trump has had
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
the first meeting which went longer than
expected two hours where there was no
note-taker only the secretary of state
in that room to provide a readout and
then this second meeting and
conversation that happened at a dinner
do you think that's appropriate should
there be others who helped record those
conversations
I think it's probably always good for
the president to have his top advisors
foreign policy national security people
in the room for meeting like that I
don't think it's unusual for a president
to have conversations with foreign
leaders I think we would expect that but
you know obviously there's a lot of
attention being paid to that
relationship with Russia right now and I
think the president has to be sensitive
to that but I certainly would expect in
most circumstances at least that he
would have those people in those
meetings who are going to be critical to
shaping America's foreign policy with
respect to Russia and other places
around the world yeah there are reports
of concerns within his inner circle and
his administration about his
relationship with Vladimir Putin senator
Jonathan thank you so much for joining
us thank you Sarah
thank you